back to back to Shanghai w8 he's out for
revenge their feet I just won again
let's see and overall we're pretty
evenly matched I'm on minus one against
him queens in Union that's an opening i
recently added to my white repertoire
but not with them yeah I don't really
know it very well c5 that's that's very
uncommon down as it allows d5 okay
that's a quite good form of the Benoni
not sure if I have to play for them but
okay yeah I benoni with the bishop on
v7s normally really frowned upon do I go
for this regrouping
yeah I guess I do maybe you can go night
to h5 that's that's losing stuff with g6
even in the lamest positions there's
tactics just losing a piece okay he
still continues let's see let's not
screw this up get out of the default
check yeah so 94 is a self-penned so
probably not let's see 94 here I ever
just make some sense therefore for
trading and possible trading h3 he has
to go back then to h6 in any case I can
also play rook t1m but I think that does
make sense night night on h6 is not
really well placed so um f5r jump to g5
so let's straight stuff on the D file
it's nothing really helps I there I have
to admit it takes takes I'm ready for
Queen D a dent and stuff like that yeah
III I guess check so Queen d8 check King
them
doesn't look like it made or anything so
let's just recap sure yeah Queen d5 I
guess is good centralizing hardly have a
bad idea keeping a five attacked yeah I
can take can check their i can trade
Queen sir where check that's maybe
enough to make him resign this check no
it isn't okay
yeah sometimes I tend to play on those
completely rusted positions as well
simply form kind of yeah because of
punishing myself and like I have to
suffer now for the stupid stuff that I
did in the game maybe he's some doing
this him okay how do I get the pawn them
nights I cannot go to be seven
unfortunately so let's get the King up
now to h4 maybe and this a bit bit
stupid that I allowed that one
yeah come on let's nest protect h3 it's
a bit stupid to play King have one then
but it's not really not really important
with that back that extra piece so how
do i get to the poor now c6 for example
so I'm c6 right getting this pawn yeah
okay and what I what I see is I only
have light them but note a little bit
check much of traits there oh that sets
in fact a bit tricky now hmm ninety-two
check
oh now that and I'll play this too too
relaxed definitely oh wow okay my nights
there a very very far away from the
action time morning well amazing yeah I
really noticed too late in this game
that it was getting tricky definitely
wow wow don't know if I'm still winning
in this position really don't know
ninety-two cooking of one I have to get
this back here night f-4s made this is a
funny thing to recognize check not
anymore but close
this test Alou in there I don't don't
see it at the moment I get the night to
t2 and then the checking b7 that could
be enough now that he can probably trade
everything right you can can get get all
the parts and that they have to prevent
but I have no time whatsoever okay wow
what the howler not winning this is
really heartbreaking
white orchids on time ah Jim I don't
know I know no comment absolutely no
comment from them I'm speechless Wow
yeah I really now played this far too
relaxed this is this is so utterly
winning that I absolutely started far
too late to think about things for real
yeah I mean okay analyzing is pretty you
sir it is complete win all along but it
it just tends to get tricky and when you
when you're f3 this is this is really
the big issue i allowed f3 i did not see
that move up to this point it's okay i
mean i have 31 minute Sergey and it is
it is a total win but you have to see f3
check and I didn't I simply didn't and
then it gets really tricky i mean what i
can do is simply this and nothing's
happening other but yeah and now i'm
covering this and i'm just winning but
as he gets gets really tricky the comp
just wants to take but I have my doubts
they have that this is yeah maybe I
should do that I it's just to pawn so
just two pawns left this can get tricky
but probably it won't like this this
Knight f3 yeah okay I should have done
that that's it so it's also much easier
to play and here it really gets
difficult it really gets difficult
at least from a practical point of
attack hunting is that and like I got a
winning position of course now but you
cannot do it with five seconds yeah even
that is of course I mean but I have
absolutely no time anymore just have to
go to the pawn and win young this is
this or whatever I it's it's just
winning but yeah 50 is and remains the
stupid outdated tag control what can you
do but I'm definitely to blame them that
I am yeah got got got into into more
practical troubles and then necessary
and yeah one of the most stupid losses i
can remember after the opponent has
blundered peace in the opening okay but
chea sometimes sometimes you make life
hard for yourself check and camp check
out the tub came like trading queens is
okay i mean i can also just take stuff
yay 6v6 everything maybe yeah that would
have been would have been easier i don't
know but okay it's a winning endgame
just have to have to win it then okay
well thanks for watching